well apple is late to the race but the
company now has a smart speaker at a
competitive price
rich jamiro explains in today's tech
smart
[Music]
apple's first attempt at a smart speaker
didn't go so well
the homepod sounded excellent but it was
just too pricey compared to offerings
from google
and amazon well now the company is back
with a much more
affordable homepod mini and this time
around it's sure to be a hit
hey siri play something i can dance to
dance now playing me
hey siri remind me to pick up some milk
okay
add it to your to-do list
apple ready to take on alexa and google
with this a 99 smart speaker called the
homepod mini
it's tiny but the sound from this
three-inch speaker is impressive device
comes in gray or white mesh fabric with
a touch area at the top
that lights up when it's listening music
and podcasts
sound great audio fills the room you can
pair two minis together for stereo sound
use them with apple tv or put a bunch
around the house for audio in every room
all in sync sonos is still easier to
control but it's way more expensive
homepod mini is the perfect companion to
an iphone with cool tricks like this
start some audio on your iphone then
just bring it near the homepod
and whatever you're listening to is
transferred right to the speaker
pretty cool siri has gotten smarter over
the years and more capable
homepod can send info to your phone
screen hey siri show me pictures of a
vampire squid
i found some web results i'll send them
to rich's iphone
homepod mini controls smart home gadgets
like this 20
nano leaf essentials smart bulb the
pairing process is
easy and apple makes automating a cinch
lights music
and more can turn on or off when you
enter or leave a room
while other smart speakers can make
phone calls apple ups the ante since you
can send texts
too a feature called intercom turns your
home pods into a pa system
hey siri tell everyone it's time for
dinner it will send your announcement to
all
of your apple gadgets it's time for
dinner
one more thing to know about the homepod
mini the power cable is fixed to the
back of the device you can't remove it
now this little speaker sounds great for
its size but it's best if you use an
iphone along with apple music or pandora
so you can get the most out of it using
your voice the homepod mini is 99
it is on sale now you can read my full
review
on my website just go to rich on tech
dot tv i'm rich demero and you are tech
smart